we have now a talk by olga torrenova who
is assistant prof the department of
mathematics of michigan state university
she will talk about a particular method
for degenerate diffusion and
applications to robotics for me thanks
olga
thank you um thanks for the introduction
and i i wanted to thank the organizers
for inviting me
and for um
allowing
folks to to speak remotely um
yeah i'm very happy to be participating
okay great so let me um
let me start the talk
um so first let me say that this
this is all joint work with um
with katie craig
and karthik along with scooty and uh
matt hepburn
okay
so first i'll talk about like the pte
that we're gonna be looking at
i'm gonna have in mind this
application to
robotics warming so i'll tell you a
little bit about that
then i'll tell you the numerical method
that we um
study
i'll give you some ideas
um
from the proofs
i'll tell you a little bit more like how
then how do we apply this to
uh the swarms
and then we'll conclude
great
so
we're gonna
pick some a nice domain
omega in our d
and um
some coefficient
uh row bar
uh that goes from omega to
r plus and both are are nice and i don't
i don't want to say now how nice
so this is the pd that we're looking at
um so notice it's a
time dependent uh degenerate diffusion
type pd
so there's the coefficient rho bar
um so it's dt rho minus divergence of
rho grad row over a bar
um and it's coupled with this boundary
condition although during the talk i'm
not actually going to talk about the
boundary condition
at all
but i put it here
for you guys to see
so notice that if this coefficient row
bar is just one
then
uh the this diffusion term
becomes just row grad row
which is a half divergence of um
gradual squared
which is of course a half of the
laplacian a row squared
uh so the reason i put this up is to
show that this pd is it's an
inhomogeneous forest medium type
equation
in other words if you want to look at
the forest medium type equations
and you want to put some in homogeneity
somewhere this is one
spot to put it
so notice um and this is going to be
important for our discussion about
robots
so
for large times
uh the solutions row
of xc converge to this row bar
so you can see this uh formally
just by imagining
this term equals zero and there's also
like factual results that say this and
even say how fast that happens
okay so let me talk about the robots
and i hope this will also um
yeah so we seek to pollinate a field of
flowers using robotic beasts
which is actually a problem that i have
heard of in um
i don't know context outside of math
so each bee
um what can it do
it each robotic b i should say can sense
whether it's over a flower
can sense whether there are other bees
nearby
and can change its velocity based on the
symptoms
bees can't communicate with each other
or with a central hub
so how do we model this
so we have some omega say in r2 which
represents the field
here
we take a row bar which represent
represents the distribution of the
flowers in omega
and we
seek to
be able we want to make like an
algorithm for controlling the bees where
robar is not known a priori
because if it were that would be
there wouldn't be much to do you could
just direct
the bees but yes so robar is not known
to the bees
and the goal is to get the bees to come
to the flowers in other words we want
the density of the swarm to be like a
robot
so let me
talk about
the numerical method that we um
introduced
so there's our rpd again
so solutions to this guy are um
wasserstein gradient flows of the
following energy so the energy of rho is
a half integral on omega rho over rho
bar zero
and so formally this is um evident from
like taking the um
functional derivative of e and seeing
that it corresponds to the correct term
in the pde and rigorously this is true
under an additional assumption on robot
which i'll talk about in a little bit
so the
main idea of the numerical method
so remember our goal is to produce a
deterministic particle numerical method
so to approximate the energy
e in a way that ensures that particles
remain particles
for example this pde itself is a
diffusive equation if you start with
initial data a sum of direct masses
they don't stay that way
and this originates from um
carrillo craig and patani from 2019 who
studied the case of constant
coefficients
so how do we um approximate this energy
so there's our energy again
one so rho over rho bar zero
and um so i'm going to be conflating
uh
measures with their density
so in particular when we
um
yeah so all measures that i that are
relevant here have density and i
conflate measure with
so i can write the energy like this
so i'm i'm going to be talking about how
we um produce this regularized
energy that i mentioned in the previous
line
um we take a mollifier
like the gaussian or say the gaussian
which is what we actually use when we
implement this method
which i show you later
and it
one of the properties that we wanted to
enjoy is that it can be written as a
convolution of two other um
modifiers that also have certain
properties
but if you want you should think of uh
this guy is the gaussian and actually
can be written as this convolution of
two gaussians
so this is what we define
how we define the energy of rho to be
the integral of rho convolved with um
zeta epsilon
where zeta epsilon is like the usual
rescaling of of our guys theta squared
over rho
and if you notice this is just
the energy
our original guy
at
rho convoluted theta
in fact there's
um
several ways to
define
an energy e epsilon that approximates e
in this sort of way and this is actually
different from what the way it's defined
in um gorilla query but to cheat
even
for robar being one i believe
but anyway so
we're really going to rely on the
radiant flow structure here so the
radiant flows of this guy are solutions
of of this fault of this continuity
equation
and we want to let me just compute this
functional derivative explicitly the
functional derivative of e epsilon with
respect to rho
is this guy
so zeta convolved with theta convoluted
rho over r
so it's um
um
so the key point
of
it and why this approximation is useful
is that solutions to
this continuity equation
with particle initial data remain
particles
so let me talk a little bit about
that this approximate continuity
equation
so
here's a
lemma
which
i'll
write out and possibly too much detail
but bear with me
so
i'm gonna
use rho sub n epsilon to denote the say
distributional solution to this
continuity equation which is the exact
same one as on the previous page
with initial data a sum of n direct
masses so that's what the the n
corresponds to the n masses and the
epsilon corresponds to the epsilon i
take
for my um
okay
hmm
there we go
so
then for t positive
um
my solution remains a sum of dirac
masses so they started at some locations
x i of zero
they're now at some locations x i of t
and i'll tell you how these locations
evolve
so these locations x i of t evolve via a
system of ods associated to this
continuity equation and i'll write it
out again explicitly um for you guys to
see
um so there's some
velocity
v epsilon
and that's
given in this complicated way
so notice the velocity
depends on the masses i started with
and
on the positions of the other
particles as well
in this particular way and that just
comes from
looking at the
this term and sort of what happens when
the row that you have here is the sum of
directness
okay
um
great
but the maybe
one key point is that if i start under
the sum of direct masses they say it
stays the sum of direct classes and
moreover there's an ode that tells you
how these masses evolve
one question sorry if i misunderstood
but
earlier you said said that robar was not
known from the bees and here you use
rubber right
so
that's a really great question so
um let's see where do i oops
let me go back
there we go
so the row bars
so the bees can sense the row bar in
their location and also nearby
so notice that the so if these zenia
epsilons are gaussian so so there's
there's a little bit of discrepancy
between the numerical method and the
amplification to roblox so for this if
you want this data to really be a
gaussian then they kind of do have to
sense robar
everywhere because the gaussian doesn't
have compact support
but in practice
um
because this guy
is really really tiny far away from
where the b is they don't actually have
to sense robar far away
just sort of see it nearby
does that yeah okay and i'll actually
address this question
probably again when i go back to talking
about the robots
i can i uh ask a quick question do you
remember the gradient of
the modifier at the origin to be zero or
can you have interactions of a b with
itself
like a drift
i think that the um
i think that the modifiers have to be
like at least we study
radial modifiers okay
thank you guys for the questions it
makes me feel more like i'm
actually there so i i really appreciate
that thank you
okay let me let me continue
okay
oh my goodness
there we go
okay so there's so let me just summarize
the numerical method so we have some
given some initial data row zero you
discretize it into n particles okay
by some whatever
your favorite way say
then you let the particles evolve via
that od system that i just wrote
where v epsilon is what was given there
and then i let row and epsilon to be
this moving
um sum
and then
so in order to get back
a nice looking density we consider
blobs over each particle in other words
let's consider row twiddle
of an epsilon which is exactly the sum
except instead of being a sum of dirac
masses it's that same um mollifier
zeta epsilon
um
but centered at the point x i
and of course this is zeta epsilon
convolved with with that sum
great
and this guy is our approximate i mean
you could think of either of the two
rows with the twiddle or not the twiddle
as the approximate solution
um
great but i think when i show the videos
or i'm sure that when i show the videos
it'll be this row bar that i show
oh great time for the videos so let's
see
how i will
hold them up on my computer
okay
[Music]
great there they are so here's the first
video i wanted to show
um so notice
here
this green line is like the row bar okay
then the
these orange dots are the x eyes
and
the blue line is like the row
and epsilon twiddle
okay
and we're gonna see
so
um one thing to look at which so my
favorite part of these videos to look at
is to see how the x eyes move around so
how the the
points x i's evolving time
so
let's let's see
there they go
oh boy
so notice that they now they've kind of
stopped so the the neat thing about this
method and also about maybe the
application to a robot is that these
guys kind of just figure out where to go
they go there and then they stop
and this is with 50
of these um
dots
okay
so let me show the next video
so again the orange dots are the
positions of the particles or of the
robots if you if you want
and
now we took the
desired guy or the coefficient to be
this discontinuous um thing so let's see
how and again there's 50 of these xi's
and because there aren't so many of them
you can see how they move so let's watch
so here it takes a little bit more time
for them to settle in because the
coefficient has has this discontinuity
and notice it doesn't quite match up
perfectly but that's because there's 50
of them and this guy is discontinuous
so for this one i want to
show
here now i believe this is 200 robots or
200 particles
so there they go because there's more of
them and sort of the blobs are thinner
they get closer to even the
discontinuous guy
but this isn't i like the other videos
more because i like to see the vlogs
moving around but here you can't really
see that
okay so i think these videos hopefully
give you an idea of um
what's going on what's the method okay
um
so let me see
great
okay
so let me just state our results
rigorously so there's uh my
collaborators
who's craig lava smoothie and hammerlin
so our assumptions on our coefficient
is that it's c1
and bounded from above and strictly away
from zero on our um omega
so the second assumption um is that rho
bar is log concave
so it's e to some v of x for some
concave uh b
and we also make some assumptions on on
the initial data
so here's the theorem that i sort of
that relates directly to the numerical
method which is that if row let row
solve the pded
and also take i guess it doesn't say it
here but take as so discretize your
initial data into n particles then as
epsilon goes to 0 and n goes to infinity
um the row and epsilon go to row
and the row twiddle go to row row
twiddle and epsilon go to row narrowly
okay
and this follows so the main
work is to prove the second theorem
uh which does the following
so let uh row epsilon b the washer
starting gradient flow of e epsilon with
initial data row zero
then the row up epsilon narrowly
converge to something
rho
and that something is the gradient flow
of e with that same initial data
so to go from the second theorem to the
first theorem you essentially just apply
you just you just essentially add in the
approximation of row zero by initial
data and control the error
so the main work is to prove the second
theorem
and that's what i'll talk about briefly
on this slide right here
okay
so
when rho bar is block concave the energy
e that we're working with is a standard
internal energy and we already know
from the work of
say ambrosio jiggly and suffering uh
that the gradient flows of this e are
well defined
so then we have to study next this e
epsilon which is this new approximate
energy that we defined we first want to
study its convexity properties
so we show that uh this guy is land of
contacts along generalized eugenics
in monster stein space
and this lambda
is negative and gets uh work it gets bad
as epsilon goes to zero
and but that's still sufficient for us
and notice that this result doesn't
require the log concavity function
which is kind of cool
so from bullet point number two we
conclude that gradient flows for e
epsilon are well defined
then we show um that gamma sorry that um
e sub epsilon gamma converges to the
energy e
so then to show the convergence of the
gradient flows uh we first obtain an
estimate that's sort of like an h1 or
for gradient so the epsilon
so formally you can get this by like
manipulating the epsilon level pde like
in the way that you manipulate these to
get estimates on norms
uh rigorously because we're working with
the gradient flows and not
and the pd formulation is so weak we use
this flow interchange method of max
mccann and subarray
and interestingly this also does not
require the log concavity assumption
so then we
uh use this to prove that the metric
slopes of e epsilon converge to those of
e
and by a general result of certainty
this
is enough
along with the gamma convergence to
deduce that gradient that gradient flows
at the epsilon converge to gradient
closing e
great
so let me return to the robots for a
minute
so remember our goal was to get the but
i think you guys already know what i'm
going to say uh because based on your
questions the goal is to get the b to
come to the flowers in other words for
the density of the swarm to be like our
row bar
so we take x zero i to be the initial b
locations
define x i of t to be the solutions of
the same od system
and then
let them evolve in that way and let row
twiddle be this blob guy
so here epsilon represents pollination
radius but also as i said earlier the um
sensing radius where where the b can
sense the values of robar and the
presence of other bees
so for small epsilon large and large t
um
so our approximate solution is like our
actual
solution but if that's for small epsilon
and large n and then for large t our
solution is like row bar
so um therefore we've achieved at least
in theory our mole of getting our
robot swarm
to be like
our
desired density or in other words to get
the bees to come to the flowers
so that's great
so uh future work
uh made so let's see what i put so rate
of convergence you can probably notice
those quotes there it would be really
nice to quantify
um them
i think the
is is pretty okay but the other two we
don't know what to do
so oh numerically we observe the
convergences of rate one over n
or better when things are super when um
your density is smooth
so another the second future work is to
remove this block concavity assumption
and notice that it was not you it was
only it was used in some parts of that
outline i gave but not in all of them so
there
is hope plus our numerics
seem to work very nicely um
even without that
when robar isn't necessarily long
concave great
so here i'm i wanna this is great from
the question that you asked
uh we want to see what happens if you
use a compact modifier so to really make
sure that the bees can only sense in a
certain radius
and
um
more general degenerate diffusion
that's also another interesting question
and maybe one other bullet point which i
don't think i put here is so my previous
slide about the applications to
to robotics warming
it's pretty much
from my
from our imagination
um it would be
if if
you're interested in actually doing
using this to control robots there is a
lot of work to be done for example
seeing what happens the contact modifier
things like this
maybe guessing these rates better if you
really want to do applications
okay
that's all
i wanted to say
thank you very
much yoga
any questions for organ
thank you that's a very nice talk so i
have a
uh question on the more technical side
so consider the n equal to infinity and
epsilon
equation
and then you said uh that you have the
result that your your let epsilon go to
zero there's convergence of gradient
flow but no convergence rate is given so
i'm thinking of another direction
suppose you fix your epsilon and then
you let t go to infinity what can we say
about the long-time convergence
so for
for the
epsilon
equals zero case because this is like a
this known internal energy
like you can
say things about in time converges
um like the um
the wasserstein norm between the
solution at time t and the
rho bar goes to zero
um
there's
like pde type work that can estimate
like the kl divergence between those two
but i don't know what happens if epsilon
is positive so for the regularized guy
um that's that's a good question
so thank you very much olga
so i had a question about uh
you know thinking at the application
with the flowers right so
the flowers they have a density
macroscopic but actually microscopically
they are there are they are actually
deltas right
so
my question is
uh so is there a way
to guarantee in some
so
of course you
so in that case you cannot observe row
bar
but you observe you know a number of uh
flowers that are in your radius
so is that a way to ensure in some way
you know that
for every
uh
call of radius say epsilon which was
epsilon is the parameter where
the vcs
uh
there is
i don't know at least one b
for every i know i don't know two
flowers or at least three bees for every
four flowers so something like that
so i think that maybe this is a question
of like
um
so
of how big of an end you need to
pollinate this field
and i think that's that's really a
question about like the the rate of
convergence um
so i think that for
like just from observing
things if your n is
not too big you still get a pretty good
um approximation
i don't know and
at least to me
i like i do really think of the flower
density as some continuous thing
because like the way that the bees
sense it i mean i would imagine one way
to sense it is by
maybe sensing like color or something
like this so you sense like where bushes
are versus where brown ground is and
bushes are sort of greenish and brown
brown
brown ground is brown
um
yeah i actually
so i started working on this
um
from
like quite enough from this robot's
perspective
with um
my co-author hamberland
who had mentored like an reu where
students actually had a robot and they
used like a stochastic algorithm to get
the robot to sense things and like go to
swarm to go to the flowers
and there in that
really
real life implementation with like
physical uh robot they really it really
worked to have it
to have the robar be like a continuous
thing
two quick questions
uh thanks all guys it's a very
interesting talk so i have a question on
the
can you comment on the computational
complexity of this dynamics i mean the
algorithm
well i can comment on it um
it's not
i gotta say it's not the best
because let me
i put so many pauses in the slides
let me go back to the slide
i want to find the slide where we write
down the v epsilon explicitly
okay
there it is
so notice that this v epsilon there is a
gradient and there's an integral so it's
it it's i certainly would not say that
it is cheap to compute
uh but i
don't have more precise comments on that
so here this integral how do you
evaluate this integral
you use particles
i'm sorry
how do you evaluate this integral over
there
oh is katie about to answer for you i'm
just sorry since i i um
uh olga has been kindly doing much of
the heavy lifting on the theoretical
side and matt and i have been working
together a lot in the numerical
implementation so i'll just comment that
uh the the integral here is something
that can be pre-computed at the initial
time um so uh
you uh this is just pre-computed as a
function of y-i and y-j um so uh for
example for certain types of think of
zetas as a gaussian so yeah sure you
have to about yeah we're assuming we
know a lot about our mollifier so maybe
even have a closed form expression for
the gradient of zeta coming in this is
something you can choose
and then
for example for simple choices of row
bar um that integral actually has an
analytic expression um for more
complicated choices of row bars for
example olga showed in one of her
simulations um like or even the
piecewise constant one actually all of
the ones she showed there's an analytic
expression for it for more complicated
choices of robar you would have to
decide how to approximate that integral
but that's something that's done in
initial time
uh and then you and then so it doesn't
um while it can you know it's something
that has to be done initially it's not
something that complete uh it factors
into the computational complexity along
the dynamics
thanks
thanks
one last question maybe the rest for the
coffee break
i'm sorry i'll keep it short i
on one of the initial slides you had a
modifier i think phi which was the
convolution of two of these zetas and
i'm not sure whether i missed the fight
disappearing later or whether i just
didn't see it anymore and so i was
wondering which road that role that
played
i think that the
it's
so where
i think that one
it doesn't play too much of a role i i
think in future versions i'll just
remove that and leave the zeta
i think it's
yeah i i i shouldn't have put that there
the reason i
yeah i
okay thank you i guess it does it it
does play a role maybe in
because we we do take and when we
implement them we really do take both of
them to be gaussians but if what like in
our um
our results apply to a more general
class
where we have some assumptions on the
zeta and some assumptions on the five so
yes
thank you for pointing
out that confusing point so i can fix it
for future presentations
thank you
do you have a last question
uh yeah i will make it shorter so uh so
you have this energy uh that with the
goal that you want to map row to row bar
so um i wonder why this particular
energy or it was more pde based
motivated because there's a nice pde and
it does happen to be this energy
the the pde i mean sorry the energy e or
e epsilon
i say e
it was motivated by the pde
and
yeah
okay thank you maybe we can have other
questions during the coffee record thank
you olga
[Applause]
thank you thank you for listening